>> WHOO!
>> ♪ SCREAM SO LOUD
GET [BLEEP] LAID
YOU WANT ME TO STAY
BUT I GOT TO MAKE MY WAY
HEY ♪
♪ YOU'RE A CRAZY BITCH
BUT YOU [BLEEP] SO GOOD
I'M ON TOP OF IT
WHEN I DREAM ♪
♪ I'M DOING YOU ALL NIGHT
SCRATCHES ALL DOWN MY BACK
TO KEEP ME RIGHT ON
YOU'RE A CRAZY BITCH
BUT YOUR [BLEEP]-- ♪
>> YOU SAVE SOME OF THAT SLUTTY
ENERGY FOR WHEN YOU'RE
CONSUMMATING THE MARRIAGE
IN A PORT-O-POTTY.
THOSE CRAZY BITCHES ARE THERESA
AND CHRIS, AND WHEN SHE
WALKED DOWN THE AISLE TO THE
SOUNDS OF MODERN ROCK ICONS
BUCKCHERRY, THERE WASN'T
A DRY CROTCH IN THE HOUSE.
A WEDDING IS A PROM
FOR ONE GIRL.
WE DON'T LET GROOMS WALK DOWN
THE AISLE BECAUSE THEY
WOULD USE THAT 40-YARD DEATH
MARCH AS A RUNWAY TO HURL
THEMSELVES THROUGH THE STAINED
GLASS WINDOW TO FREEDOM.
THE ONLY BRIDE I'M INTERESTED IN
IS MAIL ORDER.
ESPECIALLY IF SHE COMES AMAZON
PRIME AND I CAN RETURN
HER HASSLE-FREE.
WE USED TO JUST TRADE YOU LADIES
FOR SHEEP, BUT NOW YOU NEED
A $5,000 HALLOWEEN COSTUME
AND NINE SERVANTS TO PLAN YOUR
DREAM WEDDINGS THAT ARE
ALL EXACTLY THE SAME.
"LOOK, A PHOTO BOOTH
AND ALL THESE MASON JARS!
AREN'T I SO QUIRKY AND UNIQUE?"
WHEN I GO TO WEDDINGS,
I ALWAYS TRY TO BANG SOMEBODY
IN THE BRIDAL PARTY.
USUALLY THE FLOWER GIRL.
THE BIGGEST WEDDING TRADITION IN
THIS COUNTRY IS MAKING SURE
GAY PEOPLE AREN'T ALLOWED
TO HAVE ONE.
SURE, CRAZY BITCH SEEMS LIKE
AN INAPPROPRIATE
WEDDING PROCESSIONAL, BUT MOST
PEOPLE DON'T REALIZE THAT
HERE COMES THE BRIDE
IS ACTUALLY ABOUT SQUIRTING.
SO IF TERESA AND CHRIS WANT TO
TIE THE NOOSE,
I'LL FLY THEM TO L.A.
AND OBJECT TO THEIR MARRIAGE
IN PERSON FOR THIS WEEK'S
WEB REDEMPTION.
KNOCK, KNOCK. ROOM SERVICE.
LOCKS DON'T WORK.
OOH, HOO, HOO, HOO.
>> [VIBRATING] HI, DANIEL.
>> I KNOW YOU GUYS DIDN'T SLEEP
LAST NIGHT BECAUSE THIS ROOM
SMELLS LIKE SEX.
I MEAN, IT NORMALLY REEKS,
BUT YOU BROUGHT IT
TO ANOTHER LEVEL.
I GOT YOUR ORDER HERE--
LARGE CHILI CHEESE FRIES,
TWO ORANGE JUICES,
POT OF COFFEE,
AND A SIDE OF RANCH DRESSING.
STARTING YOUR DAY OFF RIGHT.
DON'T WORRY ABOUT THAT.
THE SHEETS WERE STICKY ANYWAY.
PART OF THE [BLEEP] SO GOOD
PACKAGE, COMPLIMENTARY ROLL
OF QUARTERS, AND A COPY
OF BUTTHOLE MAGAZINE.
I DOG-EARED A FEW GOOD ARTICLES.
HOW LONG YOU GUYS BEEN MARRIED?
>> YEAR AND A HALF.
>> FIRST MARRIAGE FOR BOTH
OF YOU?
>> THIRD.
>> BOTH OUR THIRDS.
>> WHAT WAS YOUR LONGEST
MARRIAGE?
WHO'S GOT THE RECORD?
>> SHE DOES.
>> YEAH.
>> 17 YEARS.
>> AND WHY DID YOU KILL HIM?
>> [LAUGHS]
>> SO THAT VIDEO WAS A YEAR
AND A HALF AGO?
>> YES.
>> YEAH, IT WAS JULY OF 2013.
>> WERE YOU SURPRISED
THAT IT WAS POPULAR?
>> YEAH.
>> REALLY?
YOU DIDN'T THINK THAT THAT WAS
THE MOST INSANE SONG
TO EVER COME DOWN TO?
AND YOU WERE THRUSTING.
A LOT OF PELVIC THRUSTS.
>> IT'S NOT LIKE I WAS THRUSTING
ON THE AUDIENCE.
>> NO, I--OF COURSE--
I'M NOT SAYING THAT YOU WERE--
WHO WAS THE ONE KID
THAT WAS BEING HELD BY--
>> THAT WAS MY NEPHEW
AND MY BROTHER.
>> AND HE WAS UNAWARE?
>> WELL, WE THOUGHT
HE WAS AWARE.
>> I THINK THE KID LIKED IT.
YOUR BROTHER WAS JUST DEFINITELY
LIKE, "OH, NO."
HAVE YOU EVER SEEN BUCKCHERRY
LIVE IN CONCERT?
>> NO.
>> WHY HAVEN'T YOU?
>> WE HAVE SEVEN KIDS.
WE HAVE SEVEN GRANDCHILDREN.
>> HOLY COW.
DO YOU HAVE ANY KIDS BETWEEN
THE TWO OF YOU?
>> NO.
>> ♪ YOU'RE A CRAZY BITCH
BUT YOU [BLEEP] SO GOOD
I'M ON TOP OF IT ♪
>> DO YOU REALLY [BLEEP]
SO GOOD,
OR IS IT JUST OKAY SOMETIMES?
>> MM.
I'VE NEVER HAD ANY COMPLAINTS.
>> WHY WOULD WE COMPLAIN?
>> [LAUGHS]
>> HOW DID YOU GUYS MEET?
>> PLENTYOFFISH.
A WEBSITE--A DATING WEBSITE.
>> IT'S CALLED PLENTY OF FISH?
>> YEAH.
>> LET'S GIVE THEM A PLUG.
>> P-O-F.
>> HOW ABOUT BLACKPEOPLEMEET.COM
YOU EVER CHECK THAT ONE OUT?
>> NO.
>> NO, BUT I THINK MY DAUGHTER
HAS.
>> OH, YEAH?
>> ONE OF THEM.
I WON'T TELL WHICH ONE.
>> WELL, I THINK IT'LL BE
OBVIOUS WHEN I SEE HER.
HOW LONG DID YOU GUYS DATE
BEFORE YOU GOT MARRIED?
>> THREE YEARS.
>> WAS SHE PUTTING THE PRESSURE
ON YOU, OR NO?
>> IT WAS THE OTHER WAY AROUND.
>> YEAH, I WAS KIND OF
PRESSURING HER.
>> YEAH?
>> I TOLD HER IF SHE MARRIED ME,
I'D MAKE HER FAMOUS AND I DID.
>> YEAH, THAT WAS ONE OF HIS
LINES TO GET ME TO SAY "YES."
>> PRETTY TOUGH TO DELIVER ON.
>> VERY TOUGH.
>> BUT LOOK AT YOU.
>> YEAH.
DOING GOOD.
>> DID YOU GUYS WRITE YOUR OWN
VOWS?
>> YES.
>> WHAT BULL[BLEEP]
DID YOU PROMISE?
>> I JUST PROMISED TO LOVE HIM
AND ROCK WITH HIM FOREVER.
>> "ROCK WITH HIM."
AH.
HOW FAR IN ADVANCE DID YOU
HAVE TO RESERVE
THAT DEAD PATCH OF GRASS?
>> THE--[LAUGHS]
>> WHERE WAS THAT?
>> OUR YARD.
>> OH!
DID YOU GUYS RENT OR BUY
THE WEDDING PARTY'S BANDANAS?
>> I BOUGHT THEM.
'CAUSE YOU KNOW, LIKE,
IN YOUR CLOSET, YOU PROBABLY
HAVE THIS WONDERFUL TIE RACK.
>> I DON'T WEAR TIES.
>> OKAY, WELL...
>> I DON'T EITHER.
>> MY WONDERFUL HUSBAND
HAS A TIE RACK THAT I IRON
ALL HIS BANDANAS
FOR EVERY DAY OF THE WEEK.
SO HE CAN JUST GO IN AND PICK
WHAT MATCHES HIS OUTFIT.
>> I LIKE THAT.
WHICH ONE OF YOU HAS THE MOST
TATTOOS?
>> HE DOES.
>> DO YOU HAVE ANY TATTOOS?
>> YES. THERE.
>> IS THAT--IS THAT HIM?
>> YEP.
>> OH, THANK GOODNESS.
>> AND THEN HERE.
>> OKAY.
I DON'T SEE ANYTHING.
>> WELL, YOU'LL HAVE TO MOVE
MY BRA STRAP.
>> OH, OKAY--I DON'T WANT TO.
>> [LAUGHS]
YOU LIKE MY NAILS?
>> WHOA.
THERE'S AN F
ON YOUR MIDDLE FINGER.
>> THAT'S THE ALBUM COVER--
>> THAT'S BUCKCHERRY'S NEW EP.
IT'S THE [BLEEP] EP.
>> WHO'S THE MOST ATTRACTIVE
MEMBER OF BUCKCHERRY?
I'LL LET YOU TAKE THIS ONE.
>> [LAUGHS]
UM, I DON'T KNOW.
I'M GONNA SAY JOSH--JOSH TODD.
>> WHAT OTHER BANDS DO YOU GUYS
LIKE?
>> OH, AC/DC...
>> ALL '80S BANDS, PRETTY MUCH.
>> '80S, YEAH.
>> ALL THE HAIR BANDS.
WHAT ABOUT MONSTER BALLADS?
YOU EVER GET THAT
COMPILATION CD?
>> YEAH.
>> AH.
IT'S NOT A BAD ONE.
>> YEAH.
>> YOU PUT MONSTER BALLADS ON
AND LET ME DRIVE WITH
THE WINDOWS DOWN,
I'M IN A GOOD MOOD.
WHO'S YOUR FAVORITE RAPPER?
>> EMINEM.
>> OH-- [SCOFFS]
THIS IS NICE IN HERE.
THIS IS A NICE BED.
WE DON'T WASH THIS TOP SHEET.
>> OH, OKAY.
>> UH-UH.
>> WELL, I'M GONNA SCOOT.
THE $80 HOLD ON YOUR DEBIT CARD
WAS DECLINED,
BUT I'M GONNA LET IT SLIDE
BECAUSE IT'S YOUR HONEYMOON.
AND I HAVE ONE LAST WEDDING GIFT
FOR YOU.
TICKETS TO SEE BUCKCHERRY
TONIGHT AT THE TULSA
CIVIC CENTER.
>> THEY'VE BEEN SOLD OUT
FOR WEEKS.
>> NO. NO, THEY WEREN'T.
UH, OKAY, HE IS DEAD.
THAT IS THE FIRST PERSON
TO DIE FROM EXCITEMENT
OVER BUCKCHERRY.
>> OR IT COULD HAVE BEEN
ALL THE COKE HE DID.
>> I'M SORRY FOR YOUR LOSS.
I WILL KEEP HIS BODY BEHIND
THE FRONT DESK UNTIL YOU'RE
READY TO CHECK OUT.
AND PLEASE RETURN THIS COPY
OF BUTTHOLE MAGAZINE
TO THE COMMON AREA.
>> [SOBBING]
[BUCKCHERRY'S LIT UP PLAYING]
♪♪
>> OKAY.
>> ♪ AND YES, I'M ALL LIT UP
♪ AGAIN ♪
♪ FLYING ♪
♪ HE LOVED THE COCAINE ♪
♪ MAMA, CAN YOU WAIT? ♪
♪ MAMA, CAN YOU WAIT? YEAH ♪
♪ HE LOVED THE COCAINE ♪
♪ MAMA, CAN YOU WAIT? ♪
>> THERE'S KIDS HERE.
>> ♪ IN THE MOMENT ♪
♪ YOU ARE JUST SO RIGHT ♪
♪ YOU'RE RIGHT, LOVE ♪
♪ ARE YOU RIGHT, LOVE? ♪
♪ AND YES, I'M ALL LIT UP ♪
♪ AGAIN ♪
♪ FLYING ♪
♪ HE LOVED THE COCAINE ♪
♪ HE LOVE THE COCAINE ♪
♪ MAMA, CAN YOU WAIT? ♪
♪ HE LOVED THE COCAINE ♪
♪ YEAH ♪
>> HER GRANDKIDS WILL BE
HAPPY TO KNOW THAT SHE GOT TO
BLOW 3/5THS OF BUCKCHERRY AFTER
THE SERVICE.
WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK, BUT FIRST,